some speculate this moment marks a
unification of the field of AI around a
single Direction treating all
perceptions as language that is a series
of information bearing symbols and then
training networks on prediction powered
by networks with self- attention this
leads to a more General system that
could be retasked on any arbitrary
narrow problem and so if we think of
intelligence as the ability to learn
this views learning as the compression
of experience into a predict model of
the world it seems that there's
something fundamental about the ability
to learn to get better at predicting
future perceptions that is core to
learning in both biological and
artificial neural networks imagination
is a great survival mechanism because it
minimizes surprise and since our actions
are part of our perceptions we also
learn the result of our actions as a
byproduct of this perception prediction
problem